hey Vsauce Michael here what's wrong are
you normal well today let's bathe our
brains with those questions and scrub
down the things that are surprising and
counterintuitive what does it mean to be
normal in the first place well maybe it
just means to be average but an average
can be a bit weird a bit misleading for
instance think of it this way the
average human has one breast and one
testicle also the average person has not
climbed to the top of Ganga insa
in fact no one has gang carpo insa is
considered the tallest mountain on earth
that has yet to be summited and it's
unlikely it ever will be soon it lies on
the border of China and Bhutan and local
governments believe the area to be holy
and no mountaineering or climbing is
allowed but don't worry there are plenty
more there are at least a hundred other
recognised Peaks that are quite tall and
remain unsummon 'add that's great it's
surprising to think that earth has so
many places that still have yet to be
conquered or explored at least we were
all born here on earth Derek from the
YouTube channel veritasium where were
you born small Australian town called
tur alga but were you really born there
[Music]
I'm suspicious of Derek's answer because
saying that you were born on Earth's
surface is like saying you were born in
a taxi cab the taxi cab may still be
around but is it in the exact same
location that it was at the moment of
your birth probably not like a taxi cab
the earth is moving and it's moving
quickly for one the earth is spinning
this is real-time footage of Earth's
spinning you don't notice much movement
at all but that's just because earth is
so large to a distant observer beyond
Earth two seconds from now you will be
an entire kilometer east from where you
are now Earth is also orbiting around
the Sun quickly three days ago I was in
Singapore from the reference frame of
Earth's surface Singapore is six
thousand kilometers away from this place
Sydney Australia but in terms of Earth
orbiting around the Sun three days ago I
wasn't - just six thousand kilometres
away I was more than seven million point
is where you were born when you were
born is now just an empty region of
space earth will never ever return to my
favourite surprise is the solution to
the three prisoners problem it's related
to the Monty Hall problem of the stakes
are higher if solution is notoriously
counterintuitive
say that myself Kevin and Jake have been
arrested and we are told that tomorrow
morning two of us will be executed we
don't know which two so it's a terrible
night but if I ask a guard to tell me
something about what happens tomorrow
and the guard says Michael I won't tell
you anything about your fate and I won't
tell you who lives but I will tell you
this little piece of information
tomorrow morning
Jake is one of the guys who will be
executed oh what a relief I used to have
a 1 in 3 chance of being the one who
lives but now that I know Jake dies it's
just between Kevin and I my chances of
living have gone up from one in three
two one and two is this great well if I
thought that I would actually be wrong
in fact my chances of living haven't
changed at all and Kevin's are
paradoxically now twice as good as mine
how can that be
we'll take a look at this
this circle represents the three
possibilities either tomorrow Jake will
live Kevin will live or I will live the
hearts represent life isn't that
beautiful now let's focus on what the
guard can tell me in the case that Jake
is the one who has been selected to live
both Kevin and myself will die tomorrow
but the guard cannot tell me anything
about myself and he cannot tell me who
lives so if Jake is the one chosen to
survive all the guard can tell me is
that Kevin will be one of the guys who
dies tomorrow that's it now in this case
where Kevin is the guy selected to live
both myself and Jake will die tomorrow
but the guard can't tell me about myself
and cannot tell me who lives so all the
guard can say is that tomorrow Jake is
one of the guys who will die here's
where it gets interesting if I am the
one who has been picked to live tomorrow
the guard has a choice he can either
tell me that Kevin is the one who will
die tomorrow or he can tell me that Jake
is one of the guys who will die tomorrow
well look at what we've got here if the
guard tells me that Jake is one of the
guys who will die tomorrow I am only
faced now with these possibilities in
one-third of these cases I am the
survivor and in 2/3 of these cases Kevin
is the survivor my chances haven't
changed and Kevin's are now twice as
good as mine used to be
[Music]
it is a beautiful day here in Sydney
before I arrived in Australia I was in
Singapore where it was also beautiful
but incredibly humid the air felt thick
to move through and breathe but in
actuality humid air is less dense than
dry air Derek tell us about Avogadro's
law well a begad robe came up with the
idea that in a given volume of gas at a
given temperature and pressure there
will be always the same number of gas
particles doesn't matter what the gas is
if it's helium or nitrogen or oxygen and
that holds true for air which is a
mixture of gases that's right
so it's got nitrogen and oxygen
principally but if it's humid air then
you replace some of those nitrogens and
oxygens with water and water is lighter
than the diatomic nitrogen and oxygen
that exists in our atmosphere right
oxygen and nitrogen have masses of 32
and 28 whereas water is just 18 humid
air is actually much less dense than dry
air it's lighter and things can move
through it more easily this is
especially true when it comes to
baseballs
a baseball travels through humid air
more easily and further with the same
amount of energy if air becomes more
humid and decreases drag by only five
percent that can mean the difference
between a fly ball and a homerun this
became a problem when indoor baseball
stadiums started to play around with the
idea of turning on the air conditioning
when the rival team came up to bat
essentially the air conditioning made
the air dryer therefore thicker and made
the rival team hit baseballs shorter
distances the word normal by the way is
home illogical what does that mean a
home illogical adjective describes
itself for instance the word tiny is
pretty tiny it's small word the word
unhyphenated is unhyphenated
normal is one of the top 1000 most
commonly spoken and written words the
word normal is normal it describes
itself but there are also words that are
heterological adjectives that don't
describe themselves for instance the
word misspelled with yes well if you
don't misspell it if you don't misspell
it what about abbreviated ooh I like
that one too
what about German German not a German
word that is a good that's a good one
how about mono syllabic that's
heterological because it doesn't
describe itself but polysyllabic for
sure I especially love just how home
illogical Pinta syllabic is yeah five
syllables what is genius yeah well it's
the way words are the way they normally
are but what about you are you normal
well a common way of defining normal is
to say that something about you is
normal if you fall within just one
standard deviation of the average for
all people but there are a lot of things
about you you can easily think of saying
36 different independent variables
different things to say about yourself
for instance how tall you are
how many friends you have how bad your
breath is or say how often you lie now
the statistical probability that you
would be normal for all 36 of those
different attributes is actually one in
a million
which means mathematically speaking it
is quite abnormal to be normal and as
always thanks for watching
[Music]